well Aloha
reject nation it is Greg Alva here and
it is John over here so we're gonna
watch from kisi how it should have ended
how spider-man homecoming should have
ended I love these because I often go I
agree or that was just funny but I also
agree before we go to this video
reaction and nod short discussion we
wanted to give a shout out to our
friends over at Stardust I'm sure you
guys have heard us talk about it before
and we are loving using the app we've
been using it pretty much every other
day it's this brand new app that allows
you to record and share your own
reactions for up to 30 seconds for any
like film TV show or even a trailer
we've got an account on there you might
have seen it already if you're a fan of
reactions movie reviews anything that we
do here you're probably gonna love using
it yourself and if you hate us Andres
for some reason watching this video what
do you want to see other youtubers that
you like using the app such as Clark
wolf John Rogo late to the party Jeremy
John's there on there too all we ask is
that you follow us first when you
download the app just so that they know
that we send you because Finders Keepers
wrote please check that out there's a
link in the description box there's a
link in the pin comment leave us a
comment too and also the cool thing is
if you share one of your own reactions
to something we could possibly feature
it in one of our upcoming movie reviews
that we did for Blake Grenier yeah sound
good sounds good to me
alright now let's watch a house hit a
minute Spider Man
look like we're done you sure we got all
the alien tech yeah this probably the
last of it here's a great idea why don't
you make sure it's the last of them
maybe you accidentally lose a truckload
of alien technology to a potential
supervillain just because you were too
lazy to safely run this department of
damage control extra I have a daughter
that makes it okay for me
[Laughter]
[Music]
I have a job that makes it okay by the
fans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the idea web sheet of configuration for
this scenario so why are you that even a
feature my friends out there don't worry
ma'am I got this I'm just gonna climb up
to the side and hope there's a way it's
off or you could just go in the entrance
and catch them from the bottom oh yeah
that'd be way easier you're really smart
you sound just like Peter Parker
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I love Liz does that mean you're gonna
kill your daughter you win this round
[Laughter]
because I do the gold me it appears that
you don't I mean that's too bad
that must be really embarrassing for you
I said now let's just hit the food trust
it's gonna make it to the new face
without any problems here's the bright
idea why don't you make sure someone
keeps an eye on all of that gear instead
of assuming nobody would want to hijack
and steal everything on this
ridiculously expensive gargle Blaine I
was wrong about you I think with a
little more mentoring you'll be a real
asset to the team
yeah to the team so when you're ready
why don't you try that on it all
introduce the world to the newest
official member of the Avengers
[Music]
so now I'm gonna bend you can you
believe it it's so awesome isn't it
awesome Tony this kid hasn't even
graduated that's here dropping out of
school to fight crime we live with the
Avengers okay
sure he can I gave him a suit and said
he's part of the team so he's part of
the team yeah yeah gave a teenager a
weaponized
super suit am I the only one that thinks
this is weird you didn't even like talk
to anime about it Peter is a miner this
feels like kidnapping I'm I'm gonna have
to take you in Tony
Iron Man be Superman now that's a
billion-dollar idea but I wouldn't want
to publicly destroy you
so I play the decline you can't you
couldn't destroy me do you think I don't
have kryptonite tank missiles up my
sleeve
do you Friday kryptonite missiles on my
to-do list please guys listen he
deserves it he's coming home and I'm a
great father figure for him
you are luring a minor to the Avengers
everything no one is replacing anything
oh really
how come you put a parachute in the new
kid suit but not my suit that's actually
met the playa what's up with that yeah
that was a design flaw it didn't occur
to me until spider-man do you have a
parachute in your suit you're replacing
me aren't you oh dear Oh mr. stark I
don't want to replace anyone you know
that would just suck yeah it does suck
yeah whole look now I know how I feel
guys I'm really sorry I guess I just
feel so lucky you know there's been all
these reboots
but I made it I'm finally home now and
now I know the level replaced me yeah
don't be too sure about that
oh man says some great stuff I don't
think I've seen one from how should have
been it was written by the fans but what
a great idea
to actually do yeah work yeah it's like
have an idea touch it up so that way
they could have it flow well and I would
be solid tight I just love that joke
about like guys so many movies are
justified by that alone yeah I have a
family or a daughter or a piece of a
family and that makes everything okay
well that's the easiest safety cat thing
when you want to be invested inside of a
villain yeah because who wouldn't go to
the ends of the earth for their family
yeah exactly it's it's a core universal
feeling but I even like the whole bit
about when I'm fighting on top of the
truck he fires like some kill blasting
from that yeah yeah kill whatever
whatever it was you would think that
Ironman would have had something
designed in there that could take down
someone like the vulture easily like no
problem easily my favorite one was at
the Washington Monument and when you see
it oh yeah he could have just done that
it also would have been cool to what
that is an intense of a sequence but
yeah I have to do is like string it up
make the little web layer so that it
would have involved then you know go up
safely and yeah if I open that door and
bring them up and you might not have had
so many police helicopter without you
event it does so well is they do these
sonars we're like yeah that could happen
but it's also really funny in the way
they executed to me this is almost like
a more lighthearted version of
cinemasins
they're pointing out plot holes yeah
still doing that but in a more like
light-hearted and these were all pretty
clever
there's spot-on yeah there's spot
everybody grabs his arm I mean that was
the one where I was like well you know
the whole thing with how he knows Peter
Parker spider-man it was identity but
can you really prove it yeah so he still
could have done something like that
mm-hm you know like are you kidding a
kid is spider-man no way
this is much faster he has no suit on it
could have done that the conversation at
the cafe I like seeing Tony Stark in
there with the Batman and Superman in
the cafe just super so unsupportive of
this yeah and Batman's not even doing
his cocky I'm Batman thing no legal and
wrong is that context there if you do
step outside and go like you know he is
just a kid
if one contextual it's funny for Batman
to be on that team too because you know
all that Dick Grayson history of raising
your own voice yeah I hope our chat a
minute as more of these more of the the
ones that are ridden by the fans or like
ideas submitted by fans maybe will
submit one maybe will submit an idea
yeah yeah yeah it's work fans
we're fans of his II his she she she
hiya is she
[Laughter]
gentle comedy well you can subscribe to
the real reject subscribe now it should
have ended up sure you've heard of them
click that notification bell followed at
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
like we said in the beginning this video
follow us on the Stardust app a lot of
your favorite youtubers are using it as
well so please follow us download the
app at the real Rejects take care types